Sunday marks the beginning of the
Chinese New Year the return of large
Valley celebrations for it health
restrictions condense them throughout
the pandemic but even with those
restrictions gone new ones could impact
international travel Brian maffey joins
us from the historic Chinatown Plaza
with what this could mean for businesses
one of the largest drivers of local
spending within our local Asian
communities that's according to the Las
Vegas Asian Chamber of Commerce but
several early pandemic day concerns
still linger from traveling Troubles
Down to Simply being accepted
crowded you cannot even drive through
John Chow is getting his noodle
restaurant ready for the celebrations
that'll be outside his front door it
doesn't help us you know to improve more
people in and no more people know about
us no more people know what's in this
Chinatown Mall and he's not the only one
casinos both on and off the strip are
hoping to bring in the crowds by
targeting their marketing for the
holiday we're over half a million people
in the aapa community in Las Vegas
that's according to Asian American
Pacific Islander Chamber of Commerce
co-founder Jenny Kim I think for CES
we've had some challenges but recently a
negative covid-19 testing requirement
dropped for those traveling from the
People's Republic of China as infections
and deaths their rise several businesses
from that country reportedly pulled out
from last week's Consumer Electronics
Show which historically would bring
thousands I think most of the people are
going to be either driving or flying in
and they're going to be local so once
they see how successful it is then we
will incorporate overseas travel
particularly for our aapi community who
have suffered the backlash of racism and
targeted after coven 19. the Las Vegas
city council acknowledging the
experiences of this community this week
just ahead of the holiday 15 days of
Celebration to bring respect and
acceptance in the New Year we just want
everybody to feel like this is part of
your community we always like that
people can live together whatever where
you've come coming from you know what
I'm saying it's a peaceful here